you can learn everything about yourself
for about $1,000 that's actually what it
costs to obtain your entire DNA sequence
or but what do you do with the
information once you have it the DNA
sequence isn't widely shared and doctors
don't always know what to look for to
identify rare diseases now genetic
analysts have a new diagnostic tool and
do arm stock of Bloomberg News is here
to give us details drew what's this all
about
how does this all work yeah this is
really fascinating you know as you
mentioned the cost of getting your DNA
sequence has fallen I think the first
time we did a human being it took you
know years and years and years and
billions of dollars now you can do it
for thousand dollars in a lab in just a
few hours and this is what taking that
you take a swab exactly just like a
little tissue swab inside your mouth a
sample of blood some hair it send it in
you send it in and you know it goes into
essentially a supercomputer and gets
processed out it's really really really
remarkable technology if you know
exactly what you're looking for and
where to look for it right so this thing
puts out these gigabytes and gigabytes
of data much of which you know we don't
necessarily know what to do with or
something like that so let's say you're
sequencing a tumor cell or something
like that you know what mutations to
look for that's one of the things that
science has gotten really good at but
let's say we don't know what's wrong
with you right there's about 25 million
Americans who have one of some 7,000
Mendelian disorders it's a defect in a
single gene shows up in childhood some
of them can be absolutely devastating
they can kill patients in didn't ears
some are extremely mild for those people
they have a lot of time spent years if
not decades trying to figure out what's
wrong with them and now all of a sudden
we have this tool that can essentially
take that huge big haystack of data and
say hey let's figure out exactly where
the needle is we're looking for let's
try to figure out exactly what's wrong
in your genome in this massive set of
data that we have and try to figure out
what it is that's gone wrong with these
people what is the gene who's doing it's
not it's a company called Clara toss
genomics Clara toss parents you know
clarity and clarity of genomics yeah and
there I'm where the
they're up in Boston they're essentially
a lab that's been partnered with Boston
Children's at the for profit
and a company called thermo Fisher that
does a lot of genetic diagnosis you know
these are the type of hospitals that see
these kids who come in and have these
very strange hard to figure out
disorders you know a lot of times you
read about these medical mysteries where
people go for their entire lives not
knowing what's wrong with them these
guys had a case where it was this woman
Jackie she was bought when she was three
years old parents started figure out
things things were wrong with her her
arms were floppy she couldn't stand up
all these motor disorders and
essentially the doctors told her take
her home enjoy her we're sorry she's
probably gonna be dead before she can
drive it's a terrible thing to learn as
a parent she's 35 now has spent her
entire life wondering what's wrong with
me why do I have these things why did I
not die when the doctors were so sure I
would she went into this company
it took essentially just a few weeks for
them to look through her genome match it
up against all these things that they
thought could be wrong or where to look
and get an answer for her and say hey
you don't have the thing that kills
people before they reach their mid-teens
you have this other milder form now
she's enrolling in some clinical trials
she's now part of this research project
that's able to help some of these people
figure out here's what's wrong with me
now can I help out in the drug
development process and try to start to
find cures for a lot of these
devastating rare mysterious diseases
that we've had for years and years and
years
Clara toss genomics yes and thermo
Fisher individual companies all right
well people can read more at Bloomberg
comm or in Businessweek stories out this
week